so this is where I strongly disagree
with the book here the author makes it
sound like that on Saturdays on Sundays
it is a regular practice that as an
associate or a consultant at McKinsey
you would need to work from my
experience this is absolutely wrong
while it is no secret that the work-life
balance at McKinsey and also other
consulting firms is not necessarily
great I can tell you that in my time at
McKinsey there were really only a
handful of weekends where I needed to
work because there was really a hard
business reason and actually I found the
contrary to be true in The Firm there's
a strong culture to keep the weak ants
free